ashley and evan are here with us now
in the la studio you guys thank you so
much
for coming oh thank you thank you for
having us oh cool
this is like a really nice outing right
now yes
drove here in the car together we're all
dressed up like bye
i mean it's so true now how old is
beautiful ziggy now really still a baby
baby but
yeah he's four months and he is so sweet
he's like the sweetest and so calm and
like easy it's
i mean it's kind of amazing yeah it's
really nice because we have such
different we have 12
5 and then four months but he when he
wakes up when ziggy wakes up he's
smiling you like everybody's like
wants to grab him as soon as he wakes up
because he like you walk into the room
and he's like
staring at you smiling and i really want
to thank you for doing a love bug
because i believe
honestly with all of my heart that human
beings are trying to figure out
relationships with other human beings
and that
is the meaning of life it could be your
mom it could be
your you know your sibling it could be
your child but
thank you for talking about love with us
of course
we love love well you guys met
at a friend's birthday as we mentioned
in our love letter to you
and um was it like love at first sight
was it fast or was it like
getting to know each other she's pretty
bold you know she kind of i mean we cut
eyes
and i think she figured it out yes
and then she's so cute and he's four
years younger than me
but it was there was something there was
a connection right away when
we you know if you know ashley she likes
to dance at a party and she
she it's it's you know it's amazing
so we definitely and i've never had a
dance off with a guy like oh i like this
because
it's you know that would be cool but it
was so much fun
you're not gonna be the only one dancing
yeah
and then we i don't know it was it we i
felt like we knew it really quickly
though we did and then we started seeing
each other and i feel like soon after we
were like oh we're getting married and
our friends were like
whoa hold on but we knew we just knew
yeah we can't say we're getting married
and all our friends something deep right
away
very early on to be zayna by the way
um evan i absolutely loved the united
states versus billie holiday and you're
fantastic in it and um
i just i loved it and i'd love to know
how your experience was making it
and the fact that you're mom full circle
it's hard to like skip over the fact
that your mom is diana ross you know i
grew up
knowing billie holiday and i'm thankful
for that because of my mom you know um i
don't know
you know if it's as much a part of
you know people's history as it should
be in schools and everything like that i
think um
this movie was so important because lee
was telling a part of the story that i
don't think that they were ready to hear
yet until now and
and the fact that you know she was being
silenced by
so many people just doing what she loved
to do and i think it's really important
and i'm glad that
i mean we're seeing now i was talking to
andre the other day
that lee and herself really did their
job because her music is being played
more now than
ever it's it's on the charts and it's
like you know so so people are
revisiting
this amazing force that billie holiday
was and uh
such a huge part of my life i know a
massive part of my mother's life and so
it's um it's nice to see everybody
revisiting
what an amazing person she was you know
i'm so glad and
you know um i love
that you guys are here to talk about
love and
i was wondering if you're okay to um
answer some questions
yes yeah okay so
um our first question is about having a
new baby in the house
and um it's from emily from mount
pleasant wisconsin
um she writes we're new parents and
exhausted
and we feel like there's no room for
romance what can we do
to not lose that spark
that's a good question i feel like we
are constantly on right now
right so there's like five twelve and a
baby you know so
and you're changing diapers all day and
whatnot but i think
for us i mean you're really good at it
too
you're like it's the middle of the day
baby's asleep but hey
you know try to get it i'm like i don't
know
it doesn't have to be at night whenever
you know find the time that's
kind of not only so smart but you're
right that isn't in the conversation
like
find it where you can that was a
brilliant answer
all right we have another one from
jessica from knoxville tennessee
we have a busy household and several
businesses that we run
together any suggestions on how to work
with your spouse
without so much drama well we went on
tour together
and um i think you learned about each
other when you
it's it's so different working together
because we know each other in
our the home life but when we were
working together i realized i was like
oh we do things very differently
you know right and how she gets prepared
how i get prepared is different and
you know how it all makes it's different
and
i think the biggest part of it is
allowing it to be that and not trying to
make the other person do it how you
would do it or whatever makes them feel
comfortable or however they want to you
know it's like you kind of gotta
realize that we we do things differently
yeah yeah and however she wants to deal
with it is how she needs to deal with
and how i need to deal with it is how i
need to deal with it you know and then
and then we could kind of i think that's
so important important because when
you're trying to
do it your way then i'm i'm not you know
i'm not going to be happy with my work
or you know
everybody has their own flow so you got
to go with that yeah
i love that so much i love it
i think that god you guys are good at
this
we're working on it yeah and that makes
me so
happy i can't thank you enough i mean
love bug with ashley and evan
and i'll say the united states versus
billie holiday is streaming now
on hulu it's so wonderful i'm so glad
andrew won the golden globe she was on
the show
and we had an amazing time and it's just
one of the most beautiful
extraordinary films i've ever seen so
thank you so much
and thank you so much let's do this
again and talk about love yeah
let's do it okay thank you so much
[Music]